what i'm really trying to get people to
understand because that's a much broader
audience that's listening right now is
how unbelievably real it is
to actually do something you like versus
actually doing something you don't like
i woke up this morning devastated about
the jets lost like sir i'm still really
really actually very very upset
but like pumped because my first two
hours were with andy and i knew we were
gonna have operational like just
hardcore operational meetings but like
pumped on september 12th from 1982 to
1998 i woke up every september 12th
monday morning devastated because it was
the beginning of a very long seven eight
months of school and now i watch people
do that every day for the rest of their
lives from 22 to 70 50 years of hating
it i only had to endure it for 16 years
people are doing things they hate for
the rest of their lives it's
unacceptable
this is the garyvee audio experience and
today i have the great privilege of
having a business partner of mine on the
show
darren will get into his back story but
this will be really fun for the
intellectual property
collectible
um just to give everyone the preview
like you know when i went on this
befriends journey there was a lot of
things i wanted to do strategically a
lot of them was around toys and
tchotchkes and things of that nature and
uh you know fate created a scenario
where we got to meet and i became an
investor in
darren's company
and it's
been a really fun journey toy keto is a
major major part of the v friends
journey which we'll get into but what i
really wanted darren on the show why i
asked him i obviously have thousands of
investments and different
individuals that could be on the show
but i tend not to do that too often
unless i feel like it actually brings
value to the audience and i feel like so
many of you are on your journeys
of being happy in life which i find
darren
to be one of the individuals i've come
across in my career that is as
passionate about the thing he does as i
am about what i do which i think is
incredibly important
excuse me um number two
i think that um
i think that a lot of you are getting
more and more interested in ip
development and things of that nature
and i think there's a lot to talk about
here and
toys and collectibles and characters and
journeys and having fun and so
how are you mate i'm good buddy thanks
for having me of course tell everybody a
little bit about yourself take take the
floor for two three minutes and give us
the kind of comic book number one or
yesterday
no worries uh so i've been in ip family
ip uh for uh 20 years so i started here
in new york working for four kids
entertainment on pokemon
with al khan back in the day
uh and then ran different how did that
happen
i caught a good question did you get
that job
what did you do exactly because i think
the reason i'm jumping in is of course i
want to get to your story but i i'm
obsessed with everyone who's listening
on the other end and i'm trying to think
about the 25 year old 24 year old right
now that's gotten affected by nfts or
comics or sports cards and actually
wants to do this too many of them
try to do their own project fail and
then take a subtle job where what they
don't realize is their biggest
opportunity is to join something
learn and then eventually get to their
own thing so i'm curious of your story
how you got to that pokemon job and was
pokemon
what did you say 21 years so yeah so
pokemon already gotten going at that
point yeah yeah i mean al had bought it
out of japan um so i joined his london
office so i got the job i mean it was by
by default of having to pay the rent
so i was working at tesco's the the
store in london working nights stacking
frozen food
and that's the walmart of uh of
the uk for everybody in europe who
everybody's listening so you're working
in retail working in retail stocking
stocking frozen peas this is even you
know i couldn't imagine a better setup
for what i'm trying to accomplish here
so keep going so you're stocking
shelves in retail stores peas no
different than what i was doing at 24.
yeah and then i saw a job application
that was looking for a merchandiser
for pokemon right and you thought and
because you were in retail you
understood at least what that
potentially meant yeah and so you
basically said i'd rather be stocking
stores with pokemon figures and cards
than peas yeah yeah and i yeah and i
i've done a
i've done a degree which included some
accounting so long story short i mean i
joined the accounting department i
didn't want to be an accountant like at
all and i had a great boss there and
after about six months he said listen
you've got two choices here i'll invest
in you to go and do all of your
accounting degrees
or you can join my sales team
because we really enjoy having you in
those meetings
because your energy was infectious yeah
i mean i went in there as the accounting
guy but ended up pitching the brand
so um so he gave me effectively what was
the duff
job in that space which was managing
what they called central eastern europe
so
i was real quick because you had a
different slang on the other side of the
palace duff was bad duff was bad yeah it
was basically the the markets that
nobody wanted right they weren't they
weren't sexy right back then nobody
wanted to go to poland correct yeah yeah
so i traveled poland czech russia
ukraine slovenia slovakia i mean and all
these beautiful places right which were
also you know obviously there's a lot
going on
in those parts of the world right now
but at what year was this twenty two
thousand this will be two thousand two
thousand one right so this is you know
the berlin wall
you know is only like a decade from
falling
these countries
are still kind of getting their footing
correct in a post-communism
era yeah and are going towards
capitalism and democracy
and there was a lot of shady [ __ ] and a
lot of exciting [ __ ] it must have been a
wild wild west market it and it was
brilliant i mean i can give you you must
have learned a ton i learned a ton yeah
did you almost get killed uh i've got
shady yeah i've got some conversations i
could give you i don't know if you want
to do them here no i think i want at
least one i mean just to paint a picture
right like
obviously i'm from that part of the
world and i was paying very close
attention to people were doing business
there and of course my parents leaving
that world were like you don't do
business in that part of the world but i
was always super curious and like you
know there was a lot of mafia a lot of
that influence in america it's like you
got to do a deal you got it's a
corporate thing right you're dealing
with corporate [ __ ] in that part of
the world you think you're trying to get
your pokemon toy into 50 local stores in
the eastern bloc and you think you're
talking to igor but what's really
happening is somebody else controls it
and you're and if you get a little too
cute and bump out a disney product you
might have a problem i'll give you a
great example tell me so i was just
handy so you think you have a tough this
isn't this is easy out here now what
darren's about to travel i was in i was
in bulgaria
and my partner at that time who was
looking to be my partner i got in the
car and he said you're gonna have to get
in the back
because in the front of the car were all
these lights and flashing and gadgets
and i said what are they and he said
well
that one tells me where the police are
and this one tells them where i am
because my business partner was blown up
last week
now i'm saying no i'm now sat in the
back of this car
[ __ ] your pants absolutely yeah
because no one knew where i was they
just knew i was in bulgaria right i
didn't know where i was in bulgaria
but um but yeah he was turning legit he
was he had a property business he wanted
to get into toys he saw the distribution
opportunity in a country that had no
real regulation of toy at that time
um and actually he went on to crush it
he's amazing
amazing yeah
see andy
you don't realize how good you have it
dust when you jump back in the car
with the camera you're thinking about
catching the right shot not getting shot
yeah
understood so keep going so you get this
pokemon gig so i get the pokemon gear
you sneak in through accounting people
see your enthusiasm you know the brand
yep and now you're in the eastern block
trying to make stuff like you're trying
to in essence get people to carry the
product yeah we're selling we're selling
the tv show onto okay so it was 360. it
wasn't just product you're trying to get
distribution for the ip as well correct
but so you were doing both or just that
no there was a great team selling the
animation in but sometimes they couldn't
sell it in so then it was up to me of
how do we get this show in
without broadcaster taking it got it so
was that being alternative distribution
or was that getting people to buy the
stuff showing them there was a demand
and then getting should i get a show by
age here so we also had uh ninja turtles
in the portfolio at that time as well
yes before it went on to be sold to
nickelodeon yes uh in the czech republic
we got ninja turtles wouldn't they
couldn't take it on air they wouldn't
take it so we packaged the toys with a
cd with a disc
right one episode per toy right so kind
of like andy and i are thinking a lot
like for example you know this because
you're our partner
we're thinking about toys with qr codes
so people watch the cartoons that was
inspired
in a lot of ways by what i saw as a kid
with he-man
my friend robbie turnick big shout out
robbie bought he-man toys before they
were cartoons and the way we cared about
skeletor and he-man was there was little
comic books later when i watched the
netflix show of toys of our childhood
they explained that the reason they had
that there was the animation wasn't
ready yet but the toys were ready and
they were going into toys r us and so
like [ __ ] we got to add a comic book
because kids aren't going to give a [ __ ]
if there's no story you did the same
thing turtles are not on tv
so to get kids to care
you had bulky toys with a big vhs tape
so that people could watch the vhs tape
fall in love with the turtles and then
create the circle and then it went on
air the following year of course because
because we created the hype yeah created
demand
um so yeah is that a wild experience to
work on so that's really where you cut
your teeth and learn the game that's
where i cut my teeth and how long were
you there uh six years and then what
happened uh and then i went on to run a
licensing agency um so we took on third
party ip
um so we represented 20th century fox we
represented sony
we represented hit entertainment and
what were your jobs you would get this
ip and your job was to to find partners
to manufacture against that ip to
license it out right licensing sure that
could mean give me an example of one of
the
you're naming the companies that owned
it for everybody listing at home in that
business all these 20th century fox give
me like a for instance we represented so
we represented the simpsons
stop right there yeah the simpsons and
you were you were doing this for what
region uh i was doing it for the
scandinavia and and i'm still in central
eastern europe at this point right so
you have you joined this agency where
for
scandinavia and centra and the europe
thing so kind of like the
you know the eastern europe scandinavia
thing
and you now have simpsons and it is your
job for example
uh for everybody who's old enough to
remember these they don't do it most
people don't do this anymore
these have been some of my favorite
licensing deals
uh
car fresheners
right yep people used to put those in
their cars which i'm sure they still do
but i'm not paying attention
you would say for instance let me go
find a car freshener partner and they'll
pay me to put a bart simpson car
freshener instead of a
pine cone right correct or toys or or
hats or cereal or anything absolutely
small give me the funniest one you can
think of that you put together during
that era just to get people's juices
going wow okay um it's andy pay
attention it's going to be going through
your work but you you may have to do
like
one of these
andy i'm going to take you back to i
mean i'm going to take you back to
russia uh if that's okay i take candy
back to russia every [ __ ] day in a
meeting so i
so ice age i say generally yes ice age
marmot right in the little thing yep
20th century fox
huge in russia
a huge brand right
it's cold there they're like the cold
thing it makes sense so i did and this
will be another good so i did a director
retail directory so this is now going
into the biggest retailer in russia
which was called uh it was called x5 x5
x5 the [ __ ] are they using western
nashville okay go ahead
i was getting excited to show my russian
knowledge give me x5 okay x5 so x5 and
then we did it vayner x5
andy
you
he's working he is working which i
appreciate i guess you could listen to
this later go ahead um so we did a deal
with x5 and they came to us with i think
50 products that they wanted to put the
ice age brand onto meaning they're
exclusives correct right this is this is
yeah they have scales this is their
manufacturing yeah right
and and then i had to go back to 20th
century fox
and say these guys in russia want to put
scratch i think was the name of the
on their toilet paper
in in every store in russia and they
said and they yeah i think we did it i
mean you the russians can wipe their
asses with our character fair enough i
get it but some how long do you do that
uh so i did that for four and a half
years and then sorry to i'm sorry if
everybody's listening be like what's
going on what's going on is what always
going on unlike all your other favorite
podcasters who do this for a living and
spend all [ __ ] week prepping for one
interview that they do for four hours
and cut down to 33 minutes i have 17
more [ __ ] meetings after this so i'm
trying to get some [ __ ] and i apologize
go ahead aaron yeah so next i joined uh
startup because i i love you you've done
the corporate thing at that point yeah
actually i yeah we'll come on to that
but i joined a startup called uh
minecandy okay so they had a brand
called moshi monsters yep um and i
joined to do everything commercial for
them that's fine away from the game
itself yes so in the world at that time
for web games there were two i remember
moshi monsters and club
yeah and disney bought club penguin and
then moshi was there their rival so
again my job was to find partners for
that but what was the most fun deal you
did there oh pez dispensers yeah
or the mcdonald's happy meal in north
america massive 33 million happy meals
in three weeks massive yeah it's huge
for that brand it gary that was the time
we had uh index and excel who are two
big vc yeah of course i know them both
so i would join the board meetings and
they didn't really care they were like
oh god there's the toy guy right they
were more into the tech [ __ ] and this is
exactly right yep but suddenly we had a
guy called bill rhodey join the board so
he set up mtv outside of north america
more of a consumer guy correct got it
and when i said we've done this um he
lost his [ __ ] mind he did yeah yeah
and he said to everyone do you know how
much that's worth you know in march
yeah of course
um
so i stayed there right through the
growth of that company from nine of us
to 220.
um yeah did that have an exit
or did it it missed its window disney
came in and they said no and they missed
it so this is this is why this is a fun
podcast i mean a funny mood i think it's
the jets thing or i've been fresh from
like the summer so i feel like a
different energy uh this is a good one
kids to listen at home a lot of you i've
seen it too many times
this must hurt you because you came in
early enough
you probably lost crucial yeah like did
you know the offer that disney made yeah
okay i was in the room good yeah so just
for everybody at home so they can learn
because a lot of you are on at a at a
startup right now and you're the seventh
employee the 19th employee you're going
through the journey economy is a little
rough right now so you're trying to
figure out your decisions but we're
going to make this real life this is
real life i want everybody to really
understand we're about to say because
darren's going to give it to us without
over sharing but he's going to give me
the math i feel because it's too far
removed and he'll be fine darren
you came in early yep means you had a
lot of shares yep
you were in the room so you it's not
here say you know exactly what disney
offered obviously the people who had the
most equity the vcs the founders decided
to pass because they could make they
thought they could make it bigger
correct
if they'd said yes you don't even have
to say what the disney offer was but if
they had said yes to that
for you personally you the human being
how much money would have that been uh
millions of dollars how many millions
three seven twenty three seven to eight
right yeah how old were you
28.
that's all you need to know yeah
28 when you started there right if i'm
doing the math of your career yeah this
offer came in so i've been like 32-33
and you see how much i'm paying
attention so at 30 i mean that is
it's was that hard for you to get over
knowing somebody else i've always
wondered about the 7th to 30th employing
companies that were in the rooms it'd be
one thing if you were the 50th employee
you weren't in the room you're not even
sure of the hearsay but like
do you feel like you took a couple of
beats of pause
when you would sleep at night of like
man this sucks i wish they said yes
yeah absolutely of course i mean but you
know what i mean i'm a i'm like you i
yeah you're about to everything happens
for a reason but did that one hurt right
yeah her for a good 12 months after it
burnt me yeah completely blind because
what happens on the other side is when
you say no
and then it's still dragging and they
lose a little momentum and you know
you've lost your window yeah
then you decided to get another job i
decided to get another job that's right
it's [ __ ] tough you go from that
where you probably at that point knowing
that you're an entrepreneur you must
have been thinking i'm going to get this
bag
i'm going to get a couple things settled
like a house or whatever
and i was and then you were like i'm
going to start my own company and i was
traveling so my wife and i we just had
our first kit
um and i was traveling 22 days of the
month if not more right you were
exhausted to make it happen right um
we've done a movie deal with universal
studios we've done a record deal with
sony you thought this was the one yeah i
thought this was it this is a home run
[ __ ] okay
so then it kind of that stock goes to
zero correct right you had your salary
but all that seven and eight's off the
table yeah you're now creeping into your
mid thirties yep but you decide to take
what job i i take a corporate job of
course you did by the way i want
everybody listen you know i always make
those andy you know this with my content
i used to say this all the time you're
all [ __ ] around you're gonna be
working at a bank in a couple years
because that's what happens when you get
burned like that and you have
responsibilities what are you going to
do you're going to over correct in the
other direction and you're going to want
to get paid more correct so you instead
of the whole i'm going to get paid 200
or 150 or 80 000 or 70 000 but i got
stuck you get burned you're like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] i'm going to get paid 400 000
300 000 yeah right yeah that's exactly
i'm sure what you did yep that's right
so i joined everyone i joined nbc
universal
to
to head up europe so let's keep talking
about this i apologize because i'm
making this selfish for my audience i
love it that must have sucked because
you went from a massive job that you had
where you had a lot of say all to say
and it was creative yeah
to
a corporation that's with all this no
disrespect to nbc they're all the same
soulless political
i i i had a boss
right suddenly had a boss again
who probably wasn't as good at not to
razz on the boss but like
i'll give you judo it's fine not because
it andy knows what it's like but he's
not as good as that i'll give you a
great example at the the boss i had i i
sat opposite him one day
and i said to him what's your dream like
what's your ambition in life i was like
i was interested
and he he just shrugged me went no this
is it i've reached i got here and i got
i went home and i'm like i can't work
there i can't be that's not inspiring
you're around people yeah but they had
some great people there as well i'm sure
and what did you learn there i learned
there so i quickly
weaseled my way into the m into the m a
team
um to learn let's talk about
weaseling sorry but
i'll tell you why
i don't know if you know this befriends
weasel is the witty weasel
and i'll tell you why andy you don't
even know this this is a v friends
exclusive
so i think and this you definitely know
andy and dustin you know this too and
even you darren are figuring it out
i like to play dumb
people don't realize that because they
see the confidence in the content but
i don't think people understand how
thoughtful and how like very specific
everything i do is i think they think
it's pretty random even and you saw the
speed in which i was creating the
characters that was my life's work
i had always used the word weaseled in
as a positive yeah you know people use
it it sounds bad like i weaseled in and
i know that it was the world meant it to
be bad
i always thought that there was a good
version of it which was like the same
way i always say god forbid but i mean
it god willing i always thought
weaseling was actually very much chess
and cleverness and if you were like a
positive weasel
like it means you weren't a weasel you
were just i always took negatives and
tried to make them positive yeah and
you're a weasel it's like slick and
you're trying to trick people but notice
how you use it you use it in a
self-deprecating way
right i find you to be very i mean
everything you're telling i don't know a
lot of these back stories but like you
know i find you to be very charming and
very likable thank you and so even in
the way you communicated as a human
being you said i weaseled my way into
mna
that's you being self-deprecating
because you're humble i actually think
what you even if you think about going
from accounting to the team that you
went to i think you're being strategic
and thoughtful
and so anyway the weasel
oh by the way andy what's the rat's name
reliable huh funny seems to be very
opposite of the way people think about a
rat a rat is the least reliable they're
the one who [ __ ] you
but the reliable rat and the witty
weasel
like i am so pumped we're documenting
all this i would watch all 5 000 hours
if i had the time of jim henson and walt
disney crafting their journey of 50
years i already know what this is all
gonna be so like this is like fun like
does the fur literally andy does not
know reliable a little bit because i
think i've referenced it in some
meetings right andy you had a little
more sense that i was playing with that
right but you definitely didn't know
[ __ ] about the witty weasel the witty
weasel is
weaseling is actually witty
it can be much more positive that's what
i want to do with be friends i want to
take things that are negative and make
them positive the [ __ ] logo of the
entire project
is a black cat
the hints were always there darren
amazing i think so
i don't even like you know i'm like
pumped right now because i like love
like
you three like even hearing this forget
about everybody who's listening but
but i don't want to give it up so easy
either i'm like damn it now they know
about witty weasel but like i really
thought about this [ __ ] and it was funny
my most inner circle was watching me we
went hardcore i was just drawing drawing
drawing it would seem like very
frivolous but it was my i've been
thinking about it forever
but you you're your level of generosity
and and with me as well you've opened
your book and your team and and with
listen i'm hugely grateful for that but
i think in those corporate jobs what i
learned is it's very hard to do that
if i'm listening i'm just pushing my
next call because i want to hang more go
ahead it was it was very hard to sort of
break down those walls because it's
almost like the military you're in your
pay grade and you're in your rank and
that's where you had to stay so i'll
give you a working example i was a town
hall phenomenal guy that ran
international for nbc
and during his speech he said they had
51 000 employees
and they reckon about 1200 of them were
digitally native
and i just come off the back of mine
candy
living in that world yeah so i just i
just emailed him just cold emailed and
said look i was in the town hall i'd
love to have a coffee love now i worked
out i was 17 runs behind the ladder for
this guy
but he met me and we had a coffee we'd
hit it off he put me on his exec
research team or something
but he found a way to get you in because
he's sensed correct yeah yeah so but
again my learning from that is i do that
with any of my team as well they've got
to be part of that journey and just
awesome let them be part yeah so then
what
so i lasted seven months at universal it
was quick it was quick and uh makes
sense i didn't even know that and notice
how i set that up and
you better not take a corporate job
go ahead and uh and then went back to
entrepreneurial i met a great guy who
made
he was uh his company was called
thinkway toys and if you turn over any
buzz lightyear from the original toy
story movie it will say think quite toys
they got the license first they got the
license amazing guy and then they resold
it no so i basically ran his global
distribution did playmates get involved
with um yeah so other toy companies
throughout that franchise playmates was
playmates was teenage mutant ninja
turtles in the us they still are still
still oh yeah darren tell everybody
while we're on the record how much i
know about this [ __ ] like like all this
like random stuff from like the 70s 80s
90s ip and toy stuff like let them know
that this is not a joke no gary's
knowledge in this space is ridiculous
and it's like i mean just looking at the
toys behind you now and you put your
passion for it i i mean
i love documentaries when the toys that
we played like that series that was i
i
want to go home right now and watch them
again but you're one of the few people
that i can
text or whatsapp
and reference something from the
raccoons
and you'll get it because it'll still be
in the memory bank you'll remember the
fact that's the other part you need to
remember the [ __ ] because i'm into it
this goes back to like i i i don't know
if anyone's paying attention we're
having a little fun we're talking a
little v friends i want you all to know
darren anybody who's in licensing toys
you should absolutely
reach out to him google and we'll we'll
do all that in the in the body but what
i'm really trying to get people to
understand because that's a much broader
audience that's listening right now is
how unbelievably real it is
to actually do something you like versus
actually doing something you don't like
it's the difference of
being
like
how darren and i wake up like i woke up
this morning devastated about the jets
lost like sir i'm still really really
actually very very upset but like pumped
because my first two hours were with
andy and i knew we were going to have
operational like just hardcore
operational meetings but like pumped
and like i just know
that on september 12th happy birthday
justin novello on september 12th
from 1982 to
1999 to 1998 which is a very long time i
woke up every september 12th monday
morning devastated because it was the
beginning of a very long seven eight
months of school something i hated okay
and now i watch people do that every day
for the rest of their lives from 22 to
70
50 years of hating it i only had to
endure it for 16 years as a child which
meant that i didn't do it all day i did
it for half a day
people are
doing things they hate
for the rest of their lives it's
unacceptable and when you dm me and
email me with your stories you don't get
it gary this my sibling this my parents
died my husband died my wife died like
there's real like when people hit me up
with some [ __ ] like you don't get it
my rent's expensive i'm like you don't
[ __ ] get it sometimes people come
with real stuff they're like you don't
get it
both my parents died i'm 19 both my
parents died in a car accident last year
i'm taking care of my seven to five and
five-year-old sibling gets real hard for
me to be like you have to follow your
passion that i understand yeah comma
i still tell that person this is one of
the worst situations on the 8 billion
people that live on earth that one can
have from a traumatic experience and i
still tell you that
tell that person with deep deep empathy
and compassion and kind and care of like
hey cool for now yeah always bet on
optimism for now you have to do that
that's right guess what for now i ate
[ __ ] also for 20 years for now you know
gary we've never spoke i don't know your
school and i'm not going to play this to
my kids i don't know what you call it
over here in the u.s but i was excluded
from two schools when i was younger does
that mean expelled yeah kicked out yeah
because you were [ __ ] at school or you
did pranks and were a bad boy i i was
just easily distracted well cool then i
if it was that i would have been
expelled from everything i haven't done
homework since fifth grade
i didn't do homework once for the last
seven years of my academic normal career
and never studied once for a test never
opened a book in high school they just
push you through the system they don't
give a [ __ ]
it's true you're lucky you got expelled
i'm proud of the uk schools during that
era my american schools could give two
shits i did nothing they just didn't
want somebody staying back for their
record not they cared about my life they
give a [ __ ]
anyway not to get too much on a tangent
talk to us about toy keto before we get
out of here yeah there was probably some
steps that we missed tell us what toy
keto is
and kind of the journey you're on and
some of the stuff you're thinking about
yeah thank you so uh we started toykido
in september 20
and and really to bring brands to life
whether it's our own brands uh that
we're developing uh we're developing a
few on different people we were taking
everything we were just listening to and
starting your own company correct right
yeah what was
what was
the
thing you did right before it because i
think we do need the context to keep
going right before you made that jump i
mean you're talking about september 2020
covid schmovid like
i i was living
the the the guy that i was working with
from thinkway toys was a phenomenal
human being like entrepreneur privately
owned business
uh and he decided to to start to wrap it
up
so did he sell it uh no he's not that
shut it down it's not that sword pass it
on to someone no
shut it down
just wind it up i had a great run yeah
i'm done i don't want to sell it because
i don't want somebody to control my
legacy sure and relationships i guess so
and i don't have any irreparent children
or whoever i guess so yeah and did he
want you to buy it uh he wanted me to do
something
for yourself for myself good for him
what a guy i know he's the best yeah can
i meet him yeah love you please
dinner that just made my
heart smile he's why he's a very high
integrity man it's why our youngest kid
is called albert wow we named it we
named our youngest after him he's an
amazing guy
unbelievable
so andy i want you to name your child
gary
[Laughter]
boy or girl
i'll give you one gary b
gary b
crane
go ahead rolls off the tongue
even doesn't like that one
all right
so yeah so um toyquitto's i mean it was
almost born out of necessity but it was
the right time
i've got 20 years of no you're the right
i mean of building other people's brands
of and there's very few investments i've
made in my career that i felt more
excited about you know what mate that
that was such a a wild week do you
remember i was down in yeah break it all
down for him remind me well i was down
in i was there in cornwall with with a
lousy reception yes and gary and i were
chatting about the project that was
going to get connected remind me i'm
blanking we were connected by uh you
know andy yep i do yeah it was it was
actually liam payne
holy [ __ ] that's right
from there and aj was talking about
halloween costumes
this was like three weeks after we sold
out this is like june 21. i'm like hey i
got a couple things to do before i can
talk about halloween costumes
but then
followed
by the way gonna keep yeah gonna keep
jumping in here to make this interesting
remember everybody was listening i
always tell you like cool but like you
know like the audacity that you darren
had this crazy career think about what
he's accomplished and he had the
humility to reach out a second third
fourth time clearly oh by the way
because me and andy get pounded
everybody in my team dust and we all get
hit up because everyone's trying to get
to me which i'm humbled by but some
people have the way the attack to do it
and others don't clearly because i know
andy gets a lot of it not only did you
reach out two or three times it clearly
andy must have been done in a manner
that was delicious versus disgusting
phone
charming
calling
of course the background display of his
office was very similar to yours yeah
that's true and then you said i should
meet yeah and then we met and i knew
right away right i remember that i
remember you know it's back to the i
remember what i felt i don't remember
the meeting but i remember thinking
there's something here i used as much of
my irish mother's charm as humanly
possible in that first meeting i love it
yeah that must have been a big deal
right that investment mattered yeah yeah
because it i mean we're only a year old
so i remember you saying to me you're
only a year old
and you were right and it was it was a
humbling experience to chat to you and
get so much time as well like we were i
don't know if you remember remember i
was behind a bush because i couldn't get
wife wi-fi reception and i came off
thinking [ __ ] this guy's gonna be like
who is this clown he's calling me from
behind the bush
but you stand but you stopped with it
and we went for it mainly because i
actually left thinking that's exactly
who i want to work with i'm not
interested in a suit and tie if you're
like hanging out of a bush doing a
meeting with me then i'm already
dramatically more interested that's
what's fun to be living on the other
side of the matrix yeah you know what i
mean you just believe in different
things like i don't believe in i
actually said something today in a
meeting the quality is the
not the production value it's the
message and you know we we we want to
like at toy keto we love working with
founders of businesses getting as close
to them so when i started the business
there were two of us myself and jeff uh
who joined me he's an ex
um
partner and in another sort of business
we worked in together
our first deal we got was with the among
us team yes monster monster for all the
parents listening you all remember that
video game exploded 500 million plus
downloads yeah
i later learned that when torquido
pitched we were up against
jack's
big company big companies i remember
when they got the wrestling ip yeah that
was their big breakthrough right
absolutely yeah yeah so there's me and
jeff versus monsters yeah you know at
the end of my pitch to them
uh i showed them a
comic strip that my 11 year old son
freddie had done
of the among us characters and i held it
up and i said listen if i get the deal
we'd love to work with you but
regardless can i just show you this
because it'll blow his mind in the
morning when i tell him that's
that level of humanity one look i think
people do business with people yeah
you know unfortunately i'm running out
of time here and i have to run
um we may need to do a part two andy
because i'm really enjoying this i want
to get a little bit deeper but a couple
things
people do business with people and i'm
sure you can't be a human being with a
pulse and not hear why this gentleman is
super interesting was for me
and and why v friends uh works with toy
keto uh so feverishly and we have all
sorts of monster stuff coming up and you
know what andy that's how we're gonna
time it we're gonna do a part two
because i feel like we have unsettled
work here on the podcast done and we'll
use that to kind of maybe launch some
more information about what we're doing
because it's all about to hit ahead here
pretty quickly
how long are you in town
tonight yeah um that's right we can do
the we can do this across the pond
virtually uh
real pleasure thank you buddy thanks for
everything love you cheers